I do think that people are psychic do I
think all the psychics that you see on
the block are actually psychic no I
definitely think there are a select few
that have the ability never heard of
Zener cards in my life now I have not
heard of Zener cards I don't know that I
realized they were called that but like
I recognized them from the movie
ghostbusters square good guess but wrong
so I guess the whole way this works is
we're guessing which shape whoever gets
the most right the winner is going to be
shot shooting the loser with this like
Ripley's gun okay so it's either River
plus sign star square or circle and I
got to figure out which one star Jordan
psychic it's a plus sign spoiler lines
ah it's sort of squiggly line circle
[ __ ] plus star square lines
I was actually guessing the next card
triangle try there is no triangle pod
concentrating really hard
it's a star na star not even a star Oh
got a raid I gotta just happen in my
mind I've got to believe in myself and
I've got to feel the power coming
through me I believe in you
[Music]
star you know what screw this game skur
it circle she got right
square square him again I don't know I
definitely feel like I would not be able
to be responsible with any sort of
psychic ability I feel like I would just
be abusing that all the time I've always
wanted to do this because I was so sure
I would totally nail it if I ever did it
so I'm never gonna do it again so I can
always say like well I she was right I
was right two out of three times I
thought that people could possess like
cool superpowers psychic abilities and I
thought I'd gain my abilities on my 18th
birthday and then that didn't happen so
after that things went downhill from
there yeah well it looks like I'm
getting shot up in there gun I'm so
sorry
um I'll try to be good to you oh my god
it's alarm I'm sorry oh oh okay I can't
I can't do that anymore I'm so sorry